English spelling is a mess ough becomes
different sounds in enough a cough
plough hiccup although thought and
thoroughly part of the reason for that
is that English has so many loanwords
whose pronunciations got either
maintained or approximated some were
written down in the way that monks would
spell that sound whenever that word
happened to enter the language plus
French scribes from the Norman invasion
Rhys pelled
English words to match French spelling
rules plus English spelling became
standardized with the implementation of
the printing press in the sixteenth
century which was the start of early
modern English but before the great
vowel shift which was well when a lot of
our vowels shifted between the confusing
spelling of English in the fact that
other european languages use different
letters for different sounds we needed
something for linguists to be able to
explain the pronunciation of words
without having to talk face-to-face so
in the late 19th century the
International Phonetic Association
worked together to create the beginnings
of the International phonetic alphabet
or IPA a century later and after a few
revisions it's now used around the world
by linguists but also by phonologists
speech pathologists singers and loads
more people the goal of the IPA is to
have a symbol for every sound in every
spoken language in the world now it does
have very Eurocentric roots the alphabet
itself is based off the roman alphabet
with some Greek letters thrown in so the
closer your language is to European ones
the more the transcriptions look like
regular Latin texts it was designed to
be easy to type without needing many
custom letter plates for printing
presses or typewriters so it also has
some rotated letters and sort of partial
symbols and the designers didn't want to
have to use a lot of diacritics they
wanted one symbol per sound and one
sound per symbol and yeah they did it
they put every sound that humans use in
speech on a chart when you make a sound
you push air out of your lungs and then
you cause some sort of constriction in
your mouth or throat to create that
particular sound to things that are
really important are where in your mouth
and throat that constriction is that's
called the place of articulation and how
much constriction you're making that's
the manner of articulation
the chart is organized based on those
two factors there's also a chart for
vowels a chart of diacritics and a chart
of extensions but we're going to focus
on the main consonant chart for this
video because there's variation from
dialect to dialect and language to
language and person to person the little
nuances of each of those sounds can be
even further narrowly transcribed using
diacritics but these are with the few
exceptions all the consonants that
humans use looking at the chart you can
see some familiar symbols those are a
great guide to help you find your way
around we can start at the top with the
plosives those are the sounds that you
make by stopping airflow somewhere and
then releasing it suddenly like a mini
explosion if you say some of the letters
that you recognise off the top row as
you move left to right you can feel
those letters moving backwards in your
mouth / to cut at the end of the row is
the glottal stop which is closing off
the air flow in your throat and it
happens in English when you say uh-oh
depending on your accent it also occurs
in Mountain Hawaii or Baja the nasal
line next down is all the sounds that
you make through your nose mm-hmm many
have trills which we don't have natively
and most dialects of English in which I
am therefore not great at pronouncing
other than really over the top then we
have taps and flaps which are like those
long trills but a tap is sort of the one
time equivalent next are the fricatives
where two parts touch so since we're the
two parts of the tip of your tongue and
the alveolar Ridge which is the hard bit
at the roof of your mouth just behind
your top teeth informally that is the
pizza ridge because it's the bit that
you burn when you bite into pizza that's
too hot and then finally there are the
approximate where two parts don't quite
meet lateral means that air is going
around sides like an or the Welsh but
not every space in the table has a
symbol some of those empty spaces have
white backgrounds and some of them are
completely grayed out the ones with
white backgrounds are possible for
humans to make but they've not been
given a symbol because linguists have
never found them actually being used as
sounds in any of the world's languages
sometimes they are found to exist by
some researchers somewhere and if that
happens then the International phonetics
Association will add as
the last time that happened was in 2005
but then there are the shaded areas the
Shadowlands the sounds that are
theorized to be impossible to produce
imagine trying to produce a sound that's
in the place in your mouth where you
make a cup or agar but using the same
method that you used to go over you need
some loose fold of tissue to make that
rapid trilling and there's just no flesh
loose enough to bounce around right at
the back of the roof of your mouth at
what's called the vellum you could I
guess in theory curve your tongue back
there but only by holding it to tends to
actually make a trill so a velar trill
is judged impossible by all means try it
in the same way if you try and cross the
place of your mouth and throat that you
used to say ha Oh with the method that
used to make the earth sound you are
going to run into problems for LA or
Elle you let our escape through your
mouth around the sides of your tongue
it's a lateral but for ha you're
constricting the air down in your throat
at the vocal folds or glottis and you
can't get your tongue down your throat
to create that Center blockage I mean
your tongue has that flexibility in your
mouth all but you can't close your
airway like you're making a figure eight
out of a straw and keep the air going
around the sides
unless you're choking on food in exactly
the wrong way and if you are that's not
really speaking a glottal lateral is
judged impossible all those shaded boxes
have the same sorts of limitations where
it's not just that they would be
difficult to pronounce they are
impossible those grey boxes are
forbidden from human speech not by
choice of some High Council or the
International Phonetic Association but
just because of the limitations of being
human sometimes we do write things that
we can't pronounce like these you can't
hold the letter P for that long or that
we're all those that at ease are silent
for more on how writing is different to
speaking my co-author Gretchen McCulloch
has a new book called because Internet
it's available now and there are links
in the description